People often talk about the whole cost
in terms of the relationship between the
Jews and the Germans are between the
Jews and the Nazis was obviously playing
the part of victims and the Nazis often
for always playing the part of the
perpetrators and of course this has
absolutely comprehensible from the
historical point of view,
but it also strikes me that if what we
remember is that the Nazis killed the
Jews that were already on the road to
making a mistake that similar to the
mistake that was,
it was made that led to the Holocaust to
begin with,
which is to identify characteristics
that lead to patterns of action of that
sort as characteristics of groups
identifiable groups.
And it seems to me,
I mean,
I'm not trying to equate the role of the
Jews and the Nazis and the Holocaust.
I would obviously be observed,
but when I'm trying to second into the
lesson,
it seems to me to be.
Especially when you consider that the
propensity for whole costs like,
uh,
events is deeply rooted in human nature.
The lesson to draw from the events of
World War II,
that's what human beings are like,
knowing what the Nazis were like because
these sorts of events happen all the
time.
I mean it's obviously the case that
there are.
There are well in the 20th century
alone,
English and benefit the concentration
camp in South Africa,
Germans,
her fact that Chinese used to great
advantage,
so an s an estimated also show this on
the next slide,
66 million people in the Soviet Union
were killed as a consequence of internal
repression,
many of whom went through camp like
procedures on their road to their
demise,
see ethnic cleansing occurring in places
like Rwanda and even once again in
Europe and the Balkans,
whatever it was that we were supposed to
learn from the events of the Second
World War hasn't been learned nor being
remembered because you can't remember
what you don't understand and that's
what this course is about.
I've been working for since 1985,
I guess the on trying to figure out what
it is about people remember hunting
around.
Maybe you know this.
Maybe she's a famous political
scientist.
She was a student of Martin heidegger.
She wrote a book called the banality of
evil,
and one of her points was that these
people,
she was talking about the Nazis in
particular,
people who perpetrate events like this,
if you meet them when you talk to them,
if you have encountered with them,
the thing that's often striking about
them is not their striking abnormality
or the resident evil,
but the fact that they're very much like
other people that you might've met,
which was supposed to be surprised.
So surprising.
When you think about how thoroughly,
for example,
the Nazi movement dominated the German
Punch with a sort of likewise with
communism in the Soviet Union.
I mean those ideological movements
characterized people,
characterized some strange sort of
misfits whose consciousness was
characterized by something in
comprehensible that led them to perform
the kind of actions that we are
theoretically supposed to remember.
My perspective on all the assistant,
the fact people are capable of
perpetrating atrocities,
light those characterize.
The whole foster says something about
why people are like,
what everybody's like because it strikes
me that that kind of tendency is
something that's deeply rooted in human
nature and then to say that,
but what was it about the Nazis or what
was it about the Soviet communists that
lend them to participate in this sort of
behavior is completely decided to point
in a sense.
All that does is you're looking for some
sort of group characteristic.
It's devoid.
You don't have any personal relationship
with that group.
The problem is instantly made abstract
and as far as I'm concerned,
if it's abstract open,
once again,
nothing is remember now.
What I want to do is to try.
I want to outline the reasons why.
Something like the Holocaust,
what it is about us that make us so
concerned with protecting art group
identities,
what those identities mean,
what role they play in the regulation of
emotion.
That's the critical thing right there
for me.
Etiologies are art are the expression in
a sense,
the verbal expression of the internal
structures that regulate our emotions.
When you mess around with someone's
ideologies,
therefore as a consequence,
you're messing around with the
inhibitory structure that regulates the
interplay between their emotions.
Whatever your identity is,
plays some role in regulating your
emotional nature and your physiology
because your thoughts are embodied.
They're part of your mind,
you're a part of your brain.
You want to get right down to it.
People have belief systems and they'll
do anything to protect,
and I find that peculiar.
What is so important about belief system
that would lead people to do things,
normal people,
as far as I'm concerned,
to commit acts that under normal
circumstances would would be conceived
of as incomprehensible even by those
people.
So I also hoped to make,
as I said,
I want to make the lessons here
personally.
I'm not interested in discussing the
issue from the abstract perspective
because I don't think that an issue,
an issue of this magnitude deserves to
be discussed.
Data at an abstract level.
It's not an abstract problem.
It's something.
There's something peculiar about us that
we have to learn to control because as
far as I'm concerned,
we're technologically powerful to remain
at the whims of the uncomprehending
aspects of our nature.